be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly
so with firestorm being introduced to
the flash TV show what we're going to do
here is we're going to go over the
character a firestorm but because the
version that we're going to see is going
to be Ronnie Raymond what we're going to
be doing is we're going to be covering
the first iteration of firestorm the
original firestorm that is to say Ronnie
Raymond and Martin Stein who were
combined into a single beam
so lemme we're even first appears in
firestorm issue number one in March of
1978 and was created by Gerry Conway but
the problem was that this first
appearance took place during the DC
explosion now for those of you who don't
know the DC explosion or his fans and
critics refer to at the DC implosion was
effectively the new 52 before the new 52
by 1975 DC had found itself falling
behind Marvel and sales due to the
launch of a multitude of Marvel titles
like the Fantastic Four the x-men and
spider-man and so as a result DC was
looking to bring in new readers by
consolidating and relaunching various
titles but instead the exact opposite
happened and over 60 titles were
cancelled while a handful of new titles
were made but among the new titles that
were created was firestorm
now with firestorms initial introduction
what we found was that we picked up with
a high school student named Ronnie
Raymond and the way Ronnie Raymond is
depicted to us as vastly different than
the way we were normally introduced to
high school students more often than not
high school students who would go on to
develop superpowers and comic books were
usually introduced to us as Seidel
outcasts
for whatever reason they just didn't
seem to fit into a social group as a
whole but stepping away from this
archetype and bringing his experience
writing various spider-man stories for
Marvel Comics Gerry Conway introduced
Ronnie Raymond as a person who stands as
a social outcast had more to do with
self-confidence than anything else
Ronnie Raymond was introduced as a star
athlete as a star football player who
already had the attention of a girl
named Doreen day and in an interesting
twist of circumstances what Gerry Conway
did was give us a situation where Ronnie
Raymond was being taunted by a school
genius a student named cliff now Gerry
doesn't really go to n depth into the
tactics that Cliff would use and
taunting Ronnie Raymond and in truth
this is really just designed to give us
an idea of where Ronnie stands in
relation to those around him but what we
find is that Ronnie Raymond's feelings
of being a social outcast will
eventually lead him to joining a group
of people who are protesting the
implementation of a nuclear power plant
and what we learn is that this group is
led by a man named Eddie Earnhardt after
seeing Eddie Earnhardt's interview on
the local news this gives Ronnie the
idea that not only can he make new
friends but he can also demonstrate to
Doreen that he's an intelligent person
and that he's also aware of word
issues but what the circumstance also
does is it allows us to I guess
transition to a man named Martin Stein
now Martin Stein has introduced to us as
a college professor who's spearheading
this whole nuclear plant program but the
problems surrounding martin stein
involves one of his former employees a
man named Danton black claiming that
Martin Stein had basically stolen his
ideas and so as a result the entire
nuclear plant program is put on hold
until an internal investigation can be
completed which will more or less
vindicate the idea of whether or not one
of these people is right but rather than
submit to the investigation
Martin decides to activate the nuclear
power plant now Gerry Conway gives us an
explanation as to why this has happened
and what Martin Stein's rationale here
is that I guess ultimately if the entire
nuclear power plant goes down then the
delay will most likely be attributed to
the fact that there's some kind of a
malfunction and by virtue of pressure
from the anti-nuclear groups people who
were against atomic energy the
government will eventually back away
leaving Martin with nothing to show for
all of his work but what we find here is
that the paths of Ronnie Raymond and
Martin Stein cross when Ronnie arrives
with Eddie Earnhardt in his group to
Martin's power plant and what we find is
that Eddie Earnhardt is actually not the
person he had made himself out to be
when he was on an interview and the way
this plays out is when Ronnie Raymond
basically learned to the plan of Eddie
Earnhardt is to plan a timed explosive
that would render the entire plant
inoperable and when Ronnie objection
threatens to notify the police
Eddie knocks both Martin and Ronnie
unconscious what we also learned is that
Danton black has apparently arrived at
the nuclear power plant and Danton
blacks entire purpose and being at this
power plan is to basically download the
files of Martin in order to verify his
falsified claims but again what happens
here is that once Danton black actually
arrives he realizes there's a timed
explosive that's prepared to go off
before anybody can actually leave what
we find is that Ronnie Raymond begins to
wake up but the nuclear explosion
detonates and as a result Ronnie and
Martin are fused together and Danton is
knocked unconscious and so from here we
learned that Ronnie and Martin have been
fused into a single body with Ronnie's
mind being in control of the body and
Martin's mind existing as a background
character now initially Jerry Conway
established that this was due to Martin
having been unconscious when the merge
initially occurred but what we'll find
in later stories is that there's
actually a
a lot more taking place with regards to
the minds of Martin and Ronnie as they
exist inside the body of firestorm what
we see taking place here is that Ronnie
begins to manipulate the various
energies that are available to him in
his firestorm form that is to say he
manipulates the ability to - I guess
manipulate atoms as well as project some
kind of energy based plasma and so he
goes on the I guess killing the purpose
of tracking down Eddie Earnhardt and
ultimately stopping any Earnhardt from
detonating a bomb at his next target now
from here what we're going to do is
we're going to move forward a little bit
and we're going to pick up with what
happens after Eddie I guess after Ronnie
Raymond and Martin have converged into
the single body and the events that take
place as they unfold with the firestorm
stories so following the origin of
firestorm in issue number one what we
found was a Gerry Conway continued to
expand on the concept of Martin Stein
and Ronnie Raymond combining into a
single being but what's really
interesting here though is that this was
a concept that didn't really exist very
often in terms of comic book characters
and this is what really struck a chord
with fans in addition to this and what
we saw was a DC was basically giving
firestorm legitimacy by introducing
Superman and issue number two and in
fact in issue number two what we found
was as Superman goes as far as to say
that firestorm if he kept along this
path would eventually be nominated by
Superman to become a member of the
Justice League but the problem that we
saw was that by issue number five
firestorm was canceled due to the DC
explosion it was rolled over into the
flash a solo series with volume 1 issue
number 289 and it was presented to us as
several 10-page featurettes but what we
found was that in addition to this Gerry
Conway had also had a firestorm ridden
into the Justice League of America and
so from here Gerry Conway continued to
basically draw on his experiences from
spider-man and that what he would do is
present circumstances whereby Ronnie
Raymond we continue to deal with
balancing the life of being a student in
addition to I guess being a superhero
and again and this really began to touch
with a lot of fans who were reading
reading firestorm comics who were
teenagers reading these stories more so
for teenagers who felt like they were
left out and what I mean by this is that
because a lot of the teenage
superhero stories that we had seen had
revolved around teenagers who were
considered nerds or geeks this story was
able to resonate with teenagers who
weren't of that group who with teenagers
who were who were Josh or teenagers who
simply just didn't fall into the
category of being kind of nerdy and so
what we found was that Gerry Conway had
began to establish the mind or I guess
the concept of what had taken place
between the minds of Martin Stein and
and Ronnie Ronnie Raymond and what we
found was that the idea of the two of
them coming together the form firestorm
was not a permanent thing that in fact
the two of them could separate but the
difference here was at Ronnie Raymond
because he was conscious when the merge
happened because he was the conscious
mind of firestorm he would always
remember what had happened he would
always remember the things that he had
done is firestorm because Martin Stein
was subconscious because he existed in
the background of firestorm he didn't
and so for him he would simply just
black out and then suddenly wake up
somewhere else and so what had happened
is that Martin Stein began to turn to
alcohol here he began to turn to various
things that ultimately cost him his
entire life cost him his job and so on
and so forth and so eventually what
happens is that Ronnie Raymond meets up
with Martin Stein to effectively explain
to him what was going on now Martin
Stein doesn't initially accept this but
what happens as Ronnie Ramon's begins to
represent him with various pictures
showing the merge taking place and so
Martin Stein acquiesce is an amiss that
this may very well be true and so what
this does is it allows him to basically
tap into the subconscious memories of
himself and ultimately begin to
recollect everything that had taken
place when he was firestorm alongside
Ronnie Raymond but again because we're
going to be focusing or because we are
focusing on the initial appearance
because of the I guess the first version
of fire soul what we're going to do here
is we're going to bring this video to an
end but let me know if you guys are
interested in seeing further iterations
of firestorm let me know if you guys are
seeing various versions of firestorm
with that being said we're going to go
ahead and burn this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace